bonjour à vous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle vidéo a aujourd'hui nous avons
parlé du programme non plus d'un
candidat mais d'une candidate marine le
pen
[Musique]
son objectif est plutôt simple elle
souhaite remettre la france en ordre en
5 ans pour ce faire elle souhaiterait la
france soit libre sur prospère juste
puissantes et durables
son projet le choix patriotes mais la
défense de la nation et du peuple au
coeur de toute décision de public mais
le pen veut défendre l'identité
nationale en faisant la promotion de
l'assimilation républicaine défendre
l'unité des français via la lutte contre
le communautarisme défendre la justice
sociale en refusant la discrimination
positive
tout cela pour la prospérité de tous les
français démocratie concernant
l'organisation démocratique du pays le
mot d'ordre de marine le pen s'est
simplifié pour économiser
elle propose donc l'abaissement du
nombre de députés de 577 à 300 et celui
des sénateurs de 348 à 200 vario optique
elle envisage de conserver que trois
niveaux d'administration communes
département et état pour supprimer les
doublons de postes pour donner plus de
poids aux élus locaux et faire des
économies sur les arts limité pour à
terme permettre une baisse des impôts
locaux pour une france forte il faut de
l'emploi et pour ça elle souhaite un
protectionnisme français dans cette
logique s opposent aux différents
traités d'échangés internationaux comme
le taffetas ou le ceta et souhaite
mettre fin à la directive des
travailleurs européens détachées c'est
ce texte qui permet par exemple à une
entreprise française de faire travailler
des ouvriers polonais sur des chantiers
français
en france elle fait le choix pour
l'emploi de la réindustrialisation du
pays de l'établissement d'une monnaie
nationale et de la conservation des 35
heures pour améliorer la situation des
jeunes
elle mise sur des filières d'excellence
maison à revaloriser le travail manuel
exemptera les entreprises de charges
pour deux ans lors d'une première
embauche d'un jeune de moins de 21 ans
dans son objectif de stimuler l'économie
réelle
l axe une partie de son programme sur
son souhait de faciliter la vie des tpe
et des pme
cela passe selon elle entre autres par
un allègement des complexités fiscale en
charge sociale crédit d'impôt est
illustrative facilité d'embauché
d'emprunt que ces dernières peuvent
rencontrer aujourd'hui concernant les
impôts marine le pen des fois un
maintien de l' isf refuse toute hausse
de la tva et indique son objectif de
baisser de 10 % l'impôt sur le revenu
des trois tranches les plus basses
elle se positionne en revanche contre le
prélèvement de l'impôt à la source
prévue pour 2010
8 et prévoit de le supprimer pour je
cite préserver la vie privée des
français sociale les questions de la
femme touche la candidate puisqu'elle
s'engage dans la lutte pour
l'amélioration du droit des femmes en
combattant l'islamisme qui je cite fait
reculer leurs libertés fondamentales
mais aussi via un plan national pour
l'égalité salariale entre femmes et
hommes
elle se promouvoir la laïcité en
inscrivant dans la constitution la
république ne se reconnaît dans aucune
communauté et prévoit d'étendre la
laïcité à l'espace public et dans le
code du travail
elle prévoit l'établissement d'une vraie
politique nataliste réservé aux familles
françaises et souhaite rétablir la
répartition du congé parental entre les
deux parents elle souhaite maintenir
l'interdiction de la gpa réserver la pma
aux problèmes de stérilité et supprime
le mariage pour tous
en créant un pacs amélioré qui remplace
les dispositions de la loi taubira sans
effet rétroactif
par ailleurs elle souhaite renforcer la
solidarité intergénérationnelle en
permettant la transmission de 100000
euros à chaque enfant tous les cinq ans
contre 15 ans aujourd'hui sécurité
pour marine le pen la sécurité passant
par l'éducation elle souhaite donc
instauré le port de l'uniforme à l'école
pour rétablir l'autorité du maître et
sanctuariser l'école comme un nazi
l'inviolable où les querelles des hommes
n'entre pas et donc on est imposant
laïcité neutralité et sécurité pour
rétablir l'ordre républicain et l'état
de droit partout et pour tous marine le
pen souhaite renforcer les forces de
l'ordre en personnel +15 mille policiers
et gendarmes
les protégés moralement et juridiquement
en instaurant la présomption de légitime
défense et moderniser les équipements et
les infrastructures
elle prévoit de les recentrer sur leurs
missions en les débarrassant des tâches
administratives et souhaite mettre en
place un plan de désarmement des cités
pour que les zones de non droit soit
reprise en main par l'état pour faire
respecter une tolérance zéro
on crée 40000 places de prison
supplémentaires ont fait supprimer les
lois laxistes
on augmente le nombre de postes de
magistrats on supprime les remises de
peine automatiques ont rétabli les
peines plancher on supprime les aides
sociales aux parents de mineurs
récidivistes et on met en place une
peine de prison de perpétuité réelle
incompressibles pour elle la sécurité
passe par une immigration contrôlée
elle propose donc de rétablir les
frontières nationales reconstituer les
effectifs douaniers et rendre impossible
la régularisation ou la naturalisation
des étrangers en situation illégale tout
en simplifiant et automatisant leur
expulsion
on supprime aussi le droit du sol et ont
durci le droit d'asile 10 comme assise
pour marine le pen une france forte
france indépendante il sera donc
nécessaire de négocier avec les
partenaires européens un projet
respectueux de l'indépendance monétaire
législatives territorial et économique
de la france suivie d'un référendum
visant à d'éventuels frais exit pour les
mêmes raisons d'indépendance
elle souhaite quitter l'otan pour que la
france ne soit pas entraîner dans des
guerres qui ne sont pas les siennes
elle souhaite que d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat 3% du pib soit investi dans
la défense pour entre autres l'achat
d'un second porte-avions le richelieu
cinquante militaires de plus la
modernisation des équipements et le
rétablissement d'un service militaire
obligatoire de trois mois minimum
remettre la france en ordre en 5 ans
pour qu'elle soit libre sur prospère
juste puissantes et durables
c'est le fondement du programme de
marine le pen et j'espère qu'il est plus
claire maintenant je vous mets dans les
sources le lien vers son programme
complet pour que vous puissiez aller
plus loin par vous même et on se
retrouve très vite pour le prochain
candidat
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
merci à tous merci à tous les types
heures de son cas financièrement le
projet on soit bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo love peace chao et pas me suivre
sur tous les réseaux